[Applause]
we passed you the ball for the good news
slam dunk and with me at the desk is the
best co-pilot in the biz rusty ross
matthew i got it i got it
all right well first up this was
interesting the movie dune um has 10
oscar nominations and is getting a
sequel oh wow
and timothy chalamet and zendaya will be
back for part two but the hollywood
reporter says they might be joined by
none other than
i'm not kidding one of my favorite
actresses in the world and rocked it as
scar joe's sister in uh black widow
florence pugh love her
she's in talk to play princess ear alone
and the deal is not final but this is
where it gets interesting florence is
one of the very finalists um for the
madonna movie to play madonna but they
film at the same time oh
plot twist you know agents are so hot to
trot right now they're like buy sell buy
sell you can have her you can't have her
you want her you got a pony app i mean
this is so fun
hollywood bananas yeah do so they're
making a second dune they just weren't
doomed yet
i didn't did you watch dune i haven't
seen dune yet i started it was really
tan like it was just taupe after taupe
after taupe do you guys know it was like
the whole color scheme was like just
i was bored it it i feel like it came
out at a time where i had a little bit
of depression and i was like i can't do
it yeah i can't go to a dry miserable
planet i just i
i i can't do it like i couldn't watch
the handmaid's tale in the middle of a
divorce you know but then a few years
later when i got my spine back i was
like bring it off bring it on
well i'm going to watch doing 10 oscar
nominations it's apparently it's great
everybody loves that yeah that's missing
out i'm going to watch this one before
dune 2 comes out okay
all right and your story all right next
up uh a news about another one of our
favorite actors chris pine yeah
whether you know him from star trek or
the princess diaries too
allure reports you've never quite seen
him like this take a look he's out in
l.a recently sporting a big old bushy
beard
he went from clean cut to grizzly man
and pinecone pull it off he did look
like this in um hell or high water
remember that movie what was so good oh
i didn't see that one either oh it was
good it was good um and don't let the
beard distract from the makings and the
clogs can you look at that again oh
yeah i'm really into this look on chris
pine i feel like we need to zoom in on
his face yeah bingo
a little closer than oh
there we go he looks like a sexy wookie
like a sexy wookie yes
yes what's a wookie i don't know
chewbacca is a wookie oh chewbacca's a
wookie yeah
or should i say
[Music]